Olá, meus amigos! Vamos para mais um vídeo.
Sejam bem-vindos ao canal.
O assunto de hoje é um tema que afeta milhões de pessoas ao redor do mundo,
que é a Síndrome do Intestino Irritável.
Então, se você sofre com dores abdominais, inchaços, constipação, diarreia ou alternância dos dois,
saiba que tem uma solução simples que poucas pessoas pensam.
É acessível e extremamente eficaz, que é o exercício físico.
Então, nesse vídeo, nós vamos falar, vamos entender como movimentar o corpo pode transformar a saúde do seu intestino.
Então, é importante você ficar até o final, porque as dicas que nós vamos compartilhar podem ser a resposta que você está procurando.
A Síndrome do Intestino Irritável é um dos estudos digestórios mais comuns e afeta por volta de 10 a 15% da população nos Estados Unidos.
A gente não tem dados confiáveis no Brasil.
E atinge principalmente mulheres.
Então, essa condição, síndrome do intestino irritável, ocorre devido a uma comunicação desregulada entre o cérebro e o intestino.
Isso resulta em sintomas como dores, inchaços, constipação, diarreia.
Os tratamentos tradicionais frequentemente incluem medicamentos sintomáticos, é o caso da trimibutina e da mebevirina.
Mas esses remédios não resolvem o problema, só aliviam alguns sintomas.
E podem ainda causar efeitos colaterais prejudiciais.
Por isso, é importante alternativas naturais, como é o assunto do vídeo de hoje com o exercício.
Você sabe que o exercício físico pode melhorar diretamente a saúde do seu intestino?
Temos vários estudos que revelam que o exercício físico atua em três áreas principais.
A motilidade intestinal, que ajuda no trânsito dos alimentos pelo intestino.
E assim, reduzindo o tempo de fermentação bacteriana e prevenindo o acúmulo de toxinas.
Um outro mecanismo é pelo aumento da produção de ácidos graxos de cadeia curta.
E esses ácidos graxos de cadeia curta beneficiam a flora intestinal com propriedades anti-inflamatórias.
E isso protege a integridade do intestino.
E a modulação do sistema imune é a terceira situação que acontece.
Isso fortalece a imunidade, ajuda a reduzir inflamações e combate o crescimento excessivo de bactérias prejudiciais.
Então pessoal, com certeza vocês já ouviram falar que o intestino é o segundo cérebro, não é?
Então essa conexão, hoje bastante conhecida, eixo intestino-cérebro, é extremamente sensível ao estresse.
Então o estresse prolongado pode desregular a microbiota ou microbioma intestinal,
levando a um desequilíbrio entre as bactérias boas e bactérias ruins.
Felizmente, o exercício físico ajuda a restabelecer essa comunicação e vai aliviar os impactos do estresse
e ainda vai promover o equilíbrio entre mente e o corpo.
Embora possa parecer tentador começar com exercícios pesados, intensos,
o ideal para quem tem a síndrome do intestino irritável é optar por exercícios de intensidade moderada.
Por quê?
Isso significa movimentar-se a um nível que você sinta uma leve falta de ar,
mas que ainda consiga conversar durante a atividade física.
Você fique ofegante, mas consiga conversar.
Então pesquisas mostram que esse tipo de exercício de média intensidade reduz o risco de lesões,
melhora a saúde geral e é mais eficaz no manejo dos sintomas da síndrome do intestino irritável.
E além disso, manter uma rotina regular é fundamental para sustentar os benefícios a longo prazo.
E para quem gosta dos exercícios orientais, yoga é uma excelente opção
para quem busca combinar exercícios moderados com benefícios específicos do sistema digestório.
Então algumas poses, como é a Corpse Pose para constipação ou a Wind Relieving Pose,
que é para gases, podem aliviar sintomas específicos de forma natural e relaxante.
Além disso, yoga reduz estresse, que é um dos principais agravantes da síndrome do intestino irritável.
Seja para aliviar os sintomas da síndrome do intestino irritável ou melhorar a sua saúde geral,
o exercício físico, sim, é uma ferramenta poderosa e acessível.
Lembre-se, a chave está na regularidade, na periodicidade e na escolha de atividades adequadas para o seu corpo.
Então, que tal começar com uma caminhada, se você não faz nada, se você está totalmente parado,
ou uma aula de yoga, se você já conhece esse assunto ou quer aprender sobre isso.
Aproveite esse conhecimento para transformar sua saúde e compartilhe esse vídeo com quem você gosta,
com quem você ama, alguém que possa se beneficiar com essas dicas.
Você é fera! Um grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração!
[Música]